what I was going with my name is piraiba
welcome to hope you bros had a nice week
um we're gonna do a vlog today basically
I did a blog a couple days ago but I
didn't really finish it so it's two days
of blogging with pants you bros really
enjoyed the last long in video I made so
I want to make another one
I'm not really good at vlogging I try
and still feel really awkward and I
really shake your camera I'm sorry about
but nevertheless I hope you was enjoy a
day two days goodbye
why do I keep doing that transition god
we are in up we are in the center look
they already have Christmas light I
think it is my cement or if s about the
game and it's for can you show it I am
in the entire haka tell us yeah thanks
okay I'm dying apparently so I want the
Silent Hill game
I keep filming in my face it's really
weird I know it's gonna suck but the
PlayStation we've done doesn't have many
game so once a game come out I'm gonna
hide all right don't judge me
when you see a bar that is cold
mozzarella bar notice your tea it's
really awesome yeah I want it on my
buddy hey guys what's up yeah really
just look socks puted you gotta do
something interesting show my body fat
oh yeah so much fat yeah my major do the
vlog all right I bought the game it's
time to blame actually no I have to make
videos we got stuck in the air yes you
and me present oh hello
it's pretty late now we got stuck in
traffic so I don't have time I have to
play video games for your bros really
like come on I want to play my video
game I was excited for the Wii U because
I am not really that excited but I'm
gonna buy it for sure and I'm gonna play
zombie you for your Bros while I'm
taking off my jacket
vlogging and taking off your data oh I'm
gonna shave die change topic right now
I'm sorry I needed to shave I've been
doing this no shave mber it's not it's
not my thing all right and you bros keep
bashing me about my mustache you know
look this is a mold I come on up packing
mole it's not my mustache being weird
okay stop zooming in all right sorry
this kid you can zoom in all you're like
all right stop there we go all right so
I'm gonna play the witch house no I
think I haven't uploaded the first one I
should be up in half an hour for your
eyes that's good
so I don't know if you bros would like
it but I think I am pretty sure you both
will like it
this is I'm going all-in on this [ __ ]
you bros better like it or else or else
you know what
dumela all right I like that I can't
show I can't show random food into my
videos cuz then someone is like did you
hear back from don't like to do that you
[ __ ] shoutout lady oh you were better
when you were out there I mean when your
shadow was new you would never shell out
into Joomla Joomla didn't pay me but
dimly I love you pay me play I've been
playing the Silent Hill game for like I
don't know 15 minutes and oh boy
hey I'll show you what what what is safe
but it is this Diablo this is supposed
to be hard
what what is this what is this what what
what what I what I what what we're going
at the party
what are we doing for Neto it's not
allowed to come nobody loves him
why is she doing ahh look in the back
you can see that is a Julius Castle and
that is Romeo's castle and there's
nothing and that's me and their pole
yeah ok
weird we're just going for a walk and
I'm gonna try to fly a little it's
really windy and it's kind of bad
weather but it should be ok
I am I gonna hike under she does leg
what the hell what do you want yeah yeah
yeah you're came to me this I know I
know
what's that oh it's pretty even though
it's kind of grey today that's still
nice I like a um ok um I like a spring a
teen oh yeah what's up she does a really
good cleaning job well I'm so bad at it
recording what my hands are so shaky
[ __ ] is my bass be yeah oh my god I'm
so fast so fast it's so fat
what did you call me fat
yes and plan just crashed nothing I will
say that you're awesome
yep I feel like I have cold what I feel
like I have cold is that how you saying
mama die sounds weird and my ears some
sounded so cold and it's really cool
okay let's go it's raining oh my god
look at the castle I really started well
I shouldn't ice dddd beautifies nuts
drills biggest thing ever
now we're going to buy my brother's
present and actually I really want to
eat it we're gonna buy that we you and
the present for it out of that even
though it doesn't deserve I'm binding we
you oh yes I'm awesome
okay so pants girl they're over here
so did you tell them that weird going to
Brighton Wow no it's a secret okay so
we're going away for two or three days
next week yeah you should you're so not
excited we are going away for we're
going to Brighton mm-hmm okay so here
it's lovely lovely city in UK we never
been in UK so we get see London get see
brighter and it's gonna be a night we're
gonna have a good time
yep need to sneeze do it bro do it do it
you should play a beautiful sneeze
I'll go write me and cry outspend I
didn't get the WiiU by the way because I
had a croco up with crying yeah noloty
brothers are like oh you've got a no
collar would cry but I cried has to go
up and like super early and for us to be
able to play together because of the
time difference
all right pres we just got done
recording that's serious it took us four
hours it was a lot of fun that game was
awesome I hope you're both may like it
out I don't think I don't think so but
yeah you know either why uh yeah I got a
ton of editing to do but it's gonna be
good alright for us I hope you enjoyed
it two days with pills um yeah I thought
it was pretty cool I think kind of same
message as last vlog I really feel like
I love my life so much and a it's thanks
to you bros that it's even possible that
I can live in the way the way I'm doing
right now so I really can't thank you
bros enough for that
we're almost at three million
subscribers which is insane as like what
the [ __ ]
wasn't like two millions just around the
corner it's just feels crazy that still
growing so fast
nearly top 10 subscribed channel on
YouTube that is just like I don't I
can't even comprehend my brain just
kissing you right
thanks for always support bras it really
really means the world to me so for that
you got to put up your brofist and wig
on bro fish stay awesome bros mah
activate